thousands of local elementary school
students are going back to class on
monday
yeah pre-k through third grade first
group they'll be in class two days a
week and learn from home the other three
then march 15th all ccsd employees
expected back
in the building grades 6 9 and 12 can
return to in-person learning
under this hybrid model starting march
22nd
grades 7 8 10 and 11 return april 6th
that'll be after spring break
also april 6th pre-k through grade 5
return
to 5 days a week in person learning but
alex even as ccsd gets
its children back in class many parents
and students say it is not happening
fast enough
yeah a lot of them are fed up they
protested before last night's school
board meeting it was the first one
in person in nearly a year now hector
mejia live this morning for us with
those details hi hector
hey there good morning and a lot of
emotions from both parents and students
saying they feel like the school
district has taken
way too long to come up with a reopening
plan well we did hear from both sides of
the issue last night but speakers
overwhelmingly
talked about reopening all campuses the
closure weighing heavy on high school
seniors in their last year who say
they were looking forward to student
rituals such as graduation
prom and sports before ccsd trustees met
last night hundreds showed up
outside to protest it was the school
board's first
in-person meeting in almost a year we
talked with a couple of students who
want the district to restore
in-person learning soon and full-time
it's been very hard for us especially
people that are graduating from high
school
not getting the opportunities that they
need to be able to progress to college
such as like scholarships
i had a lot of goals and ambitions for
my senior year i had a lot
all of those just went to waste
so pre-k through fifth grade students as
we've been telling you have the option
to start hybrid learning on monday
then ccsd middle and high school
students are scheduled to switch to
hybrid learning in late march and early
april and as far as
uh prom and graduation go for this year
the superintendent
said they are considering ways to safely
have those events hopefully
this year reporting live this morning
hector mejia 8 news now